the mlb trade deadline has come and gone
some calling it the greatest ever for
the sport with 10 all-stars on the move
including one the red sox nabbed last
night and kyle schwarber kyle schwarber
already with the red sox in tampa though
he is on the 10-day injured list with
the hamstring strain to his right side
expected to join the team possibly in a
couple of weeks it will be left-hander
josh fleming making his ninth start of
the season the record 7-5 the era just
over four
gonna hammer that one for a base set
past the shortstop franco
and a good start for boston [ __ ] stings
this angle
and a cut in the miz right there
so he strikes out verdugo
and a cut and a miss
a foul tip strikeout right back into the
mitt that is cenino
2-1 is skied into short right
the rose arena is there waiting for it
makes the catch a man left martin perez
seven and six a 418 earned run average
enemy journal
a little wide and right there works the
wall keeps the ending going here for
diaz
and he swings and hits one deep
back into left verdugo to the wall good
five
home run for diaz
johnny diaz puts the raise on top with
his seventh home run of the year
a high
pop and that ball
is stuck up there
well we saw that in the new york series
and the ball disappeared
up there somewhere on a catwalk two days
in a row how about that
2-2 skied off the bat of doll back into
deep center margo's going to be there
and makes the catch
[Applause]
going after the first pitch
sander up and over from that right side
and that'll do it
and he is out on three pitches
and that is strike three call
11 of 12
as he strikes out the side 11 strikes of
the 12 pitches he threw
oh there's a broken bat the base hit the
other way for nelson cruz
he takes this one into center that's
going to drop for a bait set toward
right center
crews will advance to second and stop
there and diaz is two for two
and now maybe wander franco can make
something happen
vanceliner into right center off the bat
of franco gonna go all the way to the
wall cruz has scored diaz going to be
waved around he's on his way to the
plate bronco with the double diaz
followed cruz to the plate makes it a
four-nothing ball game sucks have a
couple of men on and their first true
opportunity
the 0-1 hit the other way for a base hit
pograts in the third he's coming around
trying to score no play at the plate
throw back to second he's trying to
retreat and he'll be tagged out
red sex do get a run in
all right hit base hit that'll bring in
another run
anna renfro will score the rbi for bobby
dalbeck really had a nice at bat and the
red sox have cut their lead in half so
they're all filled up
[Applause]
popped up
left side of the infield that's yandy
diaz making the catch and that will end
that
mike zanino celino struck out his first
time
fly ball deep right
that sends red front of the
[Applause]
opposite field for mike cenino
on a 3-1 pitch
and the rays get one of those runs back
it's 5-2 tampa bay now
that's a shot deep to that and that
baby's going to get out of here
home run
a deep shot
off the bat of randy rosarina number 14
and the reigns again lead by four i
think that he was certain that ball was
gone
went down to get it cranks a line drive
and that's going to drop
meadows couldn't make the play here
comes in a rounding third
cut off throw is going to be sailed a
bit and another run is in down the
second hunter renfro
who connects solidly and the red sox are
within three
diving play by [ __ ] up and gunning and
gets him
he stole a hit
what a player this guy
wherever you put him he's make me the
best defensive player on the field at
that time
wander franco
that's a line drive into right center
he's gonna get a chance to run
franco on his way to second he'll cut
second head to third
and he is in there he went in head first
he could have gone in there standing up
oh and he
bounces this one in and it bounces away
from vasquez he can't find it
and coming down the line is franco
and the raids again with a four-run lead
it's 7-3
here it is
a little tapper right side
here's brandon lau making the throw to
joy and here he is making his rage debut
and a cut and a miss
there's that slider by one two three
seven nice start by chagwa here in his
first appearance
he's right down the middle he smoked
that ball toward the gap that's back
there to the wall and short hops the
fence
meadows taking up rounding third
here he comes there's a play at the
plate and he is out
that was ill-advised and he was cut down
at home plate red sox executed it well
swaying and a miss he struck him out
throughout samantha board one two the
count
down to first
short right laos there the tosser first
hot shot vogee will make the play get
the force to retire the side red sox
coming up
down 7-3
so here's jeffrey springs pitcher number
five
swinging and diminished this game is
over on the strikeout
bogarts out on strikes
and the rays win it 7-3 the final